you you've kind of suggested that
we ought to be humble about our very own
existence and that our existence
lasts only a short time uh we talked
about
um you losing your father and your
mother
uh do you think about your own mortality
are you oh yeah
afraid of death i'm not afraid you know
what epicurus actually because was a
very wise person
uh uh according to lucretius of course
didn't leave
anything in writing but uh he said that
he's never afraid of death because as
long as he's around
death is not around and when death
will be around he will not be around so
he will never meet
death so why should you be worried about
something you will never meet
uh you know and it's an interesting
philosophy of life you know
you shouldn't be afraid of something
that you will never encounter right
but there's a finiteness to this
experience
we live every day i mean
i think of her being honest with her
every day as if it's going to last
forever
we often kind of don't contemplate the
fact that it ends
you kind of have plans and goals and you
have these possibilities
uh you have a kind of lingering thought
especially as you get older and older
and older
that this is like especially when you
lose friends right
and then you start to realize um you
know
it doesn't but i don't know if you
really are cognizant of that i mean
because
so but you have to be careful not to be
depressed by it because
otherwise you lose the vitality right so
i think the most important thing to draw
from from knowing that
you are short-lived is uh
a sense of appreciation that you're
alive that's the first thing
but more importantly a sense of modesty
because
how can anyone be arrogant
if they kept at the same time this
notion that they are short-lived i mean
you cannot be arrogant because
anything that you advocate for you know
you will not be around
to do that in a hundred years so people
will just forget and move on
you know and uh if you keep that in mind
you know the caesars in ancient rome
they
they had a person next to them telling
them don't forget that you're a mortal
you know there was a person with that
duty because the caesars
thought that they are all powerful you
know
and they had for a good reason someone
they hired
to whisper in their ear don't forget
that you're mortal yeah
you